hello everyone my name is Jonathan Petro
and I carve icons that's what I do
i carve icons and make objects for
churches all over the world and I love
what I do but what I want to talk to you
about today is not about carving I'd
like to talk to you about drawing I'd
like to talk to you about a project that
I've been really excited about for the
last few years and I finally decided to
plunge into what I would like to do as I
would like to spend some time every week
to make drawings of some of the best
Christian art that's been made in
history I'd like to draw some of the
carvings from the catacombs all through
the Byzantine and post Byzantine era the
European Middle Ages Coptic art Georgian
art Ethiopian art I like to spend time
in those images making drawings of them
just why would I want to do that the
reason I want to do that is because I
would like to distill a grammar of
carved icons I would like to pull out of
all those historical elements things
that I can use into my own carvings but
also a language that I can start to to
offer even to other icon Carver's people
who would be interested in seeing what
those languages are what the what are
the differences what are the
commonalities so that's what I'm really
excited about doing and so I've chosen
to partner with patreon to do this now
patreon is a website that helps artists
find patrons the way it works is that
people donate money monthly to support a
project but I'm not asking anybody to
give me money for free at the end of the
year everybody who participated in this
project will vote on the best images and
then I will be sending out postcards and
prints to everybody who gave something
to this project
and if anybody gives more than $25 a
month they will receive an actual
drawing not a sketch but an actual
finished drawing of one of those
projects that I had been looking at
during the year so please check out my
patreon page and see if it's something
that you'd be interested in supporting
and also see if you would like to
receive a drawing for me and be part of
making icon carving better than what it
is thank you very much